so the three percent conviction rate is
a complete myth the conviction rate
currently for rape offenses in England
and Wales is around about 78 percent
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster i'm konstantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest this week is
a lawyer and a columnist at spiked Luke
it's us welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much for having me it's great
to have you before we dive into the
interview for anyone who doesn't know
who you are just tell us who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life well I'm a lawyer I
practice criminal law been practicing
criminal law for 10 years and for about
the same amount of time I've been
writing for a magazine called spiked
I've written a couple of books and
sometimes I go on the television yeah
we're delighted to have you I should
confess back yeah we did an interview
with you about a year ago it was a
brilliant interview and then the hard
drive on which that interview was stored
got dropped no falling competency yes
woeful incompetence and I bite you
should sue us yeah but we're delighted
to have you back is it was a great
interview on a very difficult and
controversial and challenging issue that
I thought you know you you you covered
beautifully which was rape culture and
we talked about at length so and why I
remember as part of it one of the
questions that Francis asked you was
isn't one of the reasons that we talk
about is that we have an awfully
terrible conviction rate for crimes like
rape and you proceeded to destroy him
for about 10 minutes and you said that
everything he said was untrue which was
my favorite part of any movie ever so we
have this conversation about rape
culture just first of all tell us what
that is and what people mean when they
talk about that well actually tracing
the origins of the idea of rape culture
or the idea that we live in a rape
culture it's quite hard to it's quite
hard to identify where that term comes
from there's a couple of cultural uses
from it in around the 1980s I think it's
used first in a television series and
then gets
picked up by academia in the 80s and 90s
and effectively it's it's a it's a term
which attempts to describe today's
society and claims that cultural factors
misogynistic media a sexually biased
justice system contribute towards the
prevalence of sexual violence and I
wrote the book that your book that I
wrote about it five years ago at a time
when time and time and again and the
term was being used to to claim that
something about today's culture
contributes to the prevalence of sexual
violence the motivation for writing the
book was to engage with what I thought
was quite a misleading climate around
this issue I've been working on these
cases at that stage for about five years
and I think he gave an insight into this
is that the fact that this is one of the
most in fact probably the most
complicated offense on the statute book
is the most complex and difficult case
crime that the courts have to deal with
for so many different reasons I think in
the majority or at least a sizable chunk
of the rape allegations that come before
the courts juries are often asked to
make very very fine distinctions often
about the real my new shy of people's
behavior and the stakes in these cases
obviously could not be higher on the one
hand you have a complainant who has made
a complaint of one of the most serious
crimes imaginable and on the other hand
you have someone accused of the most
serious crime imaginable and often we're
talking about people at the outset of
their lives on both sides of this
equation so we know from the most recent
statistics that about a third of all
rape defendants are under 24 years of
age and about 65 percent of rape
complainants are under 24 years of age
so it is a crime that has a huge effect
on people right at the outset of their
lives
and either way the court has the
potential to destroy one party's life
meaningfully I mean arguably a victim of
rape has already had an enormous trauma
and is suffering enormous Lee but it
should be clear that the stakes at play
when we consider these offences are
absolutely enormous so the purpose of
writing the book was not actually to
wade into what I think is back then had
become a kind of broadening on a culture
war between one side that said rape is
everywhere everyone is at risk men are
inherently misogynistic and all of them
are vulnerable to becoming rapists which
I don't think is true but not also to
dive into the other side which was a
kind of cultural conservatism that said
I'll well women are partly to blame for
what they wear and they should you know
make sure they dress appropriately when
they go out and I out they shouldn't
drink as much which is not true either
the reality is a very complicated mix of
factors which I'm sure we'll get into
and the purpose of the book was to kind
of try if possible to rise above the
fray of the discussion that was
happening at the time which had become
fevered inaccurate often throwing around
statistics in a very narrow and
manipulative way the book was an attempt
to sort of take an honest look at the
problems to take an honest look at what
was happening as far as we possibly can
in our courtrooms and then to test the
claims of the people who were saying we
live in a rape culture and hold them
open to scrutiny because I think that
the the severity of these crimes and the
stakes at play in these cases mean we
have to be honest we have to be
searching and we have to interrogate the
claims that both sides make about them
and the book was a kind of modest
contribution to that effort and I mean
the problem with this crime is that the
level of feeling on both sides of it I
mean you even look at the case that
happened in Cyprus now I've only been
following it but you know you have you
know on one side you know the people who
have been accused who were then
acquitted who then seen the cells as
immuno they what they were right they
were correct and then you have the girl
on the other side who is you know
into court covering her face I mean how
do you deal with a crime like that which
is so I mean all crimes are polarizing
but particularly in something like rape
well so taking the cyprus case first
it's incredibly difficult to say
anything about because we know nothing
about the specifics of the allegation I
think our first order position should be
to trust in general that the Cypriot
justice system is working that should be
the presumption and then we test and
investigate further who knows what
happened in the course of that case and
I can't really comment but I think
you're right to say that these cases
generate enormous emotion on both sides
but I think what is often missed in the
in the contemporary debate or all the
headlines that feature around it this is
starting to change actually but one
thing that used to be missed was the
catastrophic impact it has on both sides
because often the discussion rightfully
focused on complainants and victims of
of sexual violence because obviously the
impact is catastrophic but there is
another side of the coin and often when
you go into these cases if you look at
the background and you look at the
evidence what one of the most shocking
things I found from look from looking at
these cases was that often two people
had a fundamentally different account of
what took place but also they had a
fundamentally different understanding of
how to interpret what took place so two
people can come to these cases with the
same understanding of what factually
occurred but different understandings as
to how to interpret it and I think if
you put yourself in the mind of someone
who is accused of this crime
and say well I went into that
interaction that I had that that that
sexual liaison that I had and I came out
with a completely different
understanding of what had happened
and I'm now accused of the most serious
possible crime facing ten years in
prison it's important that we
acknowledge that that dynamic has to be
taken seriously we can't simply say well
every conviction is good any fallen
convictions is bad
we must charge more people we must
prosecute more people that is a far too
simplistic approach to take to this
offense which by its nature is
is involves a great deal of moral
complexity one of the common slogans if
you like of the people who talk about
rape cultures being a real thing is that
the conviction rate most sexual offences
is incredibly low people say the
conviction rate for rape is 3%
etc and this is something I've heard
over and over and over but of course in
your book this is one of the things you
talked about so give us your views on on
that idea so the three percent
conviction rate is a complete myth the
conviction rate currently for rape
offenses in England and Wales is around
about 78 percent which is actually
unusually high the reason for the
confusion is that people are confusing
the attrition rate with the conviction
rate now this gets technical very
quickly but the attrition rate describes
the percentage of allegations or reports
to the police which are flagged up as
rapes which end eventually in a
conviction and that figure oscillates
between around 3% and 6% there's all
sorts of reasons why cases fall out of
the justice system between when the
report is made and when the case is
finally disposed of at court
that could be because the person making
the complaint is simply mistaken about
what they're reporting okay so the kind
of the number of reports will include
reports made by third parties or people
completely unrelated say oh I think I'm
hearing something here that will be
bounded up in that initial set of
reports so that that initial number will
be narrowed down because quite simply
most of the calls will not relate to an
actual crime that's taken place and then
throughout the different stages in the
justice system there are reasons why
reasons why cases drop out the evidence
might not be adequate enough which means
that the CPS won't charge the case which
means cases fall out at that stage and
what you end up with is this figure of
between three to six percent of the
reports made initially that end in a
conviction now what's important to
remember is the attrition rate for rape
is not particularly low when considered
in relation to like for like cases if
you look at offenses like burglary or
GBH the attrition rate is roughly the
same because in relation to all crimes
there's going to be an enormous amount
of initial reports that don't get taken
forward for a number of different
reasons
but there is nothing to say that the
attrition rate for rape is particularly
low in fact when that's the attrition
rate that people usually talk about when
they say 3% the conviction rate is the
rate of cases which reach court and end
in a conviction
now there's other complications and
caveats to that but the conviction rate
for rape has been high and has always
been high it was at 2:00 in 2013 it
reached an all-time high at 63% then
it's now at 78% on the latest statistics
so by the time a case gets into court
78% of those cases will end in a
conviction which is way more than half
okay so three out of four people who get
charged with rape and that gets taken to
court will be convicted of know that the
more you delve in said that the language
use is very important because it's not
so you have various stages of the case
you have people getting charged at point
X that's after the investigation is
completed and when the prosecution
formally begins yes but those cases can
fall out before they reach court yes the
conviction rate refers to the percentage
of cases that reach court and end in a
conviction now the additional
complicating factor is not all cases
that reach court on an allegation of
rape will end in a conviction for rape
okay and the Ministry of Justice
Statistics taken this into account where
the CPS statistics don't I'm telling you
it's technical very quickly but so there
is some evidence from the Ministry of
Justice Statistics that the figure of
78% won't necessarily correlate with 78%
of people being convicted for rape they
might be convicted with something less
but nonetheless once the cases get to
court there is a good chance that the
person accused of rape will be convicted
of rape if you look at the
research the only research that's been
done recently into real live juries that
was conducted in 2010 by the home office
commissioned Commission and academic I
think at UCL the findings there was that
there was juries were consistently as of
2010 more likely to convict her than
acquit so they were more likely to
convict rape defendants than they were
to acquit them no evidence whatsoever of
racial bias or bias against women who
wore anything particular or or or had
any particular attitudes so um and and
no evidence whatsoever that this that
once the case got in front of the jury
that they were bias against rape
complainants so the key message from all
the research is to trust juries and one
of the reasons why I was worried about
this issue was because it's so often
used as a stick to beat up the jury
system you know the allegation is that
juries don't understand these cases they
get them wrong they don't convict but
actually if you look at the all the
figures over the last 10 to 15 years the
conviction rate is consistently high
there are all sorts of other problems
which we can come on to talk about as to
why that number of reports don't
progress because there are absolutely
real problems with the way this offense
is policed absolutely under-resourced
and police the police often struggle and
often held back by a whole host of
different factors but once the case gets
to court there is every reason to
believe that that case will be given a
fair hearing and it's part of the
problem why the reason why they there is
that fallout of cases in-between the
attrition rate and going to court the
fact that rape is a very very difficult
crime to prove yeah because a lot of it
comes down to he what he she he said she
said or am I getting this completely
wrong and I am now a toxic figure for
saying no you're not getting it wrong
that I think what you need to what there
are a number of factors which could
contribute to cases falling out okay so
firstly you're right and often not
always but often rape allegations
involve one person
at the beginning coming forward and
saying this is how I experience this
interaction what the police ought to do
is take that seriously investigate to
the best of their abilities marshal any
resources they have to investigate the
veracity of that allegation and find out
whether there is a basis in fact I'm
afraid what often happens is that the
police can take a derisory attitude to
complainants they say oh well she was
asking for it or you know that does
still happen undoubtedly even if they
don't explicitly say all she was asking
for I'm sure she was up for it or
something similarly appalling they will
simply take a relaxed attitude to
actually investigating the case
so one thing we see time and time again
is the police simply not taking the
steps that they would do if this was a
robbery or a murder case because they
think well there's no big pressure
because we'll eventually be able to
dispose of this in a way which covers
our back but which doesn't pay proper
credence to the veracity of the
allegation so there's all sorts of
issues with the police why is that
sergeant or what why would they care
less about rape than they do let me let
me take that generalization I've just
made and qualify it because they were
also incredibly voracious and eager
detectives out there working on these
cases I've seen examples of both
detectives who take a relaxed attitude
and detectives who will go way beyond
what you would expect in trying to prove
a particular allegation so there are and
I think that culture in the police is
really starting to change we had a
report in 2005 from Dame and Giuliani
who cited this as a problem that under
resourcing and perhaps retrograde
attitudes had led to cases falling out
and I think since then things are
starting to change you do have
specialist officers who are desperate to
get results in particular cases when it
comes to I think the answer to your
question Constantine is what why does
some officers take this approach because
I think generally there are still
officers out there with quite old-school
retrograde attitudes about sexual
morality which say you know if she was
out in a nightclub wearing a short skirt
and she went home with a bloke then she
probably consented to have sex with him
that's an appalling idea I don't think
it's common among the police but I think
those attitudes still probably exist but
isn't that what people talk about when
they talk about rape culture they do but
the the claim that they make is that
that is so pervasive that it can explain
the prevalence of sexual violence across
society which I don't think is true I
don't think those kind of attitudes are
so prevalent that it's enough to explain
the prevalence of sexual violence what
we know about sexual offenders is that
when you look at the vast majority of
people we would consider sort of serious
serious sexual offenders they are serial
offenders in there a very small portion
of the population which is hardly a
surprise you know the actual people that
go out and target women for sexual
violence is a vanishingly small
percentage of the population and those
people are not affected by culture okay
there is no evidence to suggest for
example there was a lot in the 80s and
90s researchers trying to prove the
connection between sexual violence and
pornography so again and again academics
have tried to prove that the more you
watch porn the more likely to engage in
sexual violence and even when you look
at people who are watching violent
pornography there is absolutely no
connection between people who watch
violent pornography and and the
prevalence of rape even less so is there
a connection between other cut you know
some of the factors that are sometimes
talked about as contributing to rape
culture you know when I wrote the book
the song the Robin Thicke's on it's a
ridiculous song you know you know she
wants it all that that was cited as
contributing to rape culture so the idea
being that this song plays a part of a
culture which encourages young men to
commit sexual violence and one thing
that was and of course that's ridiculous
but what happens is that what started to
happen was men who are actually
convicted of sexual violence started
blaming the culture that they were
raised in so I remember a number of
times
rape defendants who have been convicted
started coming for and said well I
couldn't help it
I was part of a culture that encouraged
me to do it or sort of subliminally for
Smith it didn't Ted Bundy also do that
you know it was yeah there was I think
that's right there he had but it I think
it's a common trope yeah among people
who especially who could make violence
against women yeah they feel able to
rely on cultural influences to explain
away
their behavior and I don't think you
know even the most sophisticated people
who argue for the existence of a rape
culture don't go so far as to say that
they have no weight that these people
have no agency they just say that it
sets a context for their behavior but I
do think it's a slippery slope when you
say well because that because that Rugby
Club listen to Robin Thicke and was
dancing around being idiots that makes
them more likely to commit sexual
violence well then it's an it's it's a
natural step for someone who is
eventually convicted of sexual violence
to turn around and say well you know
what do you how can you blame me I'm
part of the culture that's inherently
misogynistic I'm not entirely
responsible for my behavior and when it
comes to considering criminal cases
actually those fine argument you know
the kind of the little bits of influence
actually to do meaningfully detract from
people's agency you can make an argument
that if someone for example has a mental
illness they still have agency but their
responsibility is diminished and that's
why the people make these arguments
because they're saying their
responsibility is diminished now I think
that you know when it comes to people
who the other thing I've learnt from
looking at these cases is when people
commit these offenses and the cases that
you look at which are pretty cut-and-dry
you can see that they're going out and
making a moral choice to behave in the
way they are they're making a decision
and often when you sit down and talk to
them you can see that this isn't the
result of something cultural it's a
moral decision that they have made
they've decided to go out and commit an
act of violence and this is another just
to follow that up the feminist what's
one very interesting change is that
that's occurred in the kind of feminist
discourse around rape and sexual
violence is that in the 80s rape was
considered a crime of power and violence
and there was an attempt to by academic
people like Germaine Greer and others to
divorce rape from sex because the two
are very very different things
in fact when someone raped someone
that's not a sexual act it's a violent
act we've lost that distinction now and
I'll discuss at the discussion that we
have today tends to conflate rape and
sex and
and rape and sexual etiquette in a way
which is very troubling
and so when I make the argument that you
know when someone decides to go out and
commit an act of sexual violence they
are going out to commit an act of
violence they're not going out just for
sexual gratification they're going out
to exert power over someone and that's a
that's an understanding we've had for a
long period of time but now because of
this argument around rape culture we
conflate people like Robin Thicke who
likes to dance around with women in
their underwear with rapists which is a
very peculiar conflation to make
considering the history of this
discussion because you never in the past
would have understood rape as a mere
extension of someone's sexual preference
or a development of a particular of a
particularly sort of sexualized piece of
art you would understand it as a violent
moral choice made on behalf of the
rapist and I think the danger is we
losing that distinction actually has
some quite troubling consequences I
think we're delighted to have a brand
new sponsor for those of you who are
interested in learning a foreign
language might we've got predominately
British audience none of them are going
to be interested in learning a foreign
language
yeah that's true also know who's really
traveling right now it's a foreign
country but when when the coronavirus is
over those of you who are still left on
this planet might be interested in
second language and that's why Babel is
a great place for you Babel is great
because they have a website and an app
which allows you to learn a new language
with 10-15 minutes snippets every day in
a clear and simple way which is great
for people like Francis who are simple
absolutely and also as well when you're
in quarantine what else you gonna do you
can try Babel completely free simply
head over to babble dodo UK or download
the app and you can try it completely
free that's right guys go on to
www.sba.gov
it's gonna ask so you you obviously look
at all these people the vast majority of
whom in fact but I imagine all of them
but are there any other common patterns
between these types of people who commit
these crimes or is it just people from
every pop society every color all the
rest of it yeah I don't think you can
make any generalizations about color
class or anything like that really I
mean the law is crafted by the way so
that only men can commit rape you have
to penetrate someone with a penis and
although that is still true that yeah
I'm afraid at least when it comes to
this area of the law we are quite strict
on biology so women can't commit rape
they could commit conspiracy to rate if
they planned to assist someone else but
so it is only men who are charged and
convicted of rape women can be convicted
of sexual assaults actually all other
sexual violence but the law requires
penetration with the penis when it comes
to rape but no I don't think you can
generalize I've but but I think I would
draw a distinction between two sets of
people what I have experienced is that
this offense has the capacity to draw a
wide net of people into the criminal
justice system who I don't believe
should be there I think that's true
primarily because as we've discussed
allegations are easily made and
difficult to prove and so people can
often you know we've and I think the
discussion around this has really
started to change since 2018 because we
saw cases like Liam Allen's where Liam
spent something like two years under
investigation
having been charged was about to face
trial and it was only on the eve of his
trial that the Crown Prosecution Service
disclosed text messages completely
disproving the allegation against him
and that's a young man who could have
used that you know he would have been
totally justified in having his life
completely turned upside down I mean he
did have his life turned completely
upside down but luckily he's been able
to come back from that but these are the
stakes that were playing with and this
is an offense with the capacity to draw
more and more people into its net in a
way which perhaps robbery murder or
burglary you know most people won't ever
be accused of
but burglary murder or violence without
some basis when it comes to sexual
violence the lines are a lot more
difficult to draw because as you've said
it often involves one person's word
against another it can often involve the
the my new show of people's behavior and
different understandings of how a
situation played out and where do you
stand on because we have anonymity for
victims which I perceive I'm an
agreement whereby I think that's a good
thing
do you think there should be anonymity
for the accused and if not why not
I think so anonymity for the victims
came in in the 1970s and initially it
was anonymity on both sides I think I'm
right about the 1970s I might be wrong
but am initially it was anonymity for
both parties and then it was taken away
for defendants I think that creates a
difficult dynamic the presumption of our
justice system is that it takes place in
the open and the both parties are
exposed to public scrutiny I think
you're right to say that there are
benefits from complainants having
anonymity because obviously giving
evidence in court is a deeply traumatic
process however I think that um the
presumption should be that everything
should happen in the open and I
certainly don't think the answer to
remedying the cut would I think there is
a current inequality between the parties
because one side has the entitlement to
be anonymous and the other side doesn't
I don't think the corrective to that is
to make both sides anonymous because we
want to be able to scrutinize in the
best possible way what happens in our
courtrooms you know justice is meant to
be done in our name and the more that
criminal justice processes are done
behind closed doors they're more likely
or possible that it is that things go
wrong without us knowing about it now
there's all sorts of qualifications that
because people who ask for anonymity for
defendants make the point that they
could waive their right to anonymity to
open up the scrutiny you know public and
they won't have control over it but I
think there are other possible
difficulties so anonymity so when people
argue for anonymity for defendants they
often say that that anonymity should
certainly be in place up until charge
and then once they're charged
then they should be revealed but that
actually creates a that has real impacts
with the presumption of innocence
because a charged person has not yet
been convicted is not yet guilty and I
think if you have anonymity up until
charge once someone is charged it
creates the idea that they should have
their rights taken away well why does
the right to anonymity exist before
charge and not afterwards it shouldn't
change if you if you're if you're
arguing that defendants should remain
anonymous there's no reason to take that
right of anonymity away at the charged
stage because they're still an innocent
person they're still they still should
have all the rights of an innocent
person I think allowing anonymity only
up until charge creates the idea that
once they're charged they're effectively
open season a little bit so I think
there's that's problematic so I I mean I
think it's a difficult argument to make
but I think that the proper response
should be to remove anonymity entirely
with the caveat that we should take as
many steps as we possibly can to make
the process of giving evidence easier
and we do this year we saw trialing of
pre-recorded cross-examination of
complainants okay that's a big step it
means that what used to happen live in
front of a jury is now videotapes and
played to them okay and that's an
enormous leap in favor of complainants
comfort at the expense of a defendant's
traditional right of a fair trial
because traditionally a defendant would
be able to sit in court watch the
complaint be cross-examined and that
would be a robust exchange now that
process is can be and this is only
piloted and it looks like it might go
further be pre-recorded I don't agree
with those steps because I think we have
to be honest with complainants that the
criminal justice system has to be and
will inevitably be a deeply
uncomfortable process to go through I
mean when you make a an allegation of
rape or sexual violence if you go to
core sadly you are going to have your
account tested robustly
because otherwise the conviction that
results from it is not going to be based
on a fair process we have to be honest
with complainants and
look we're you've gone through an
appalling you know assuming they are
genuine victims for a moment you've gone
through an appalling attack this next
bit it's going to be awful but it's an
important process to make sure that if
this if your attacker is convicted that
they got the best shot possible at
defending themselves because if you deny
a defendant the right to defend
themselves against these allegations or
you dilute the powers and rights that
they have in that process the eventual
conviction
I think is increasingly diluted because
they haven't had the best possible
opportunity to test the evidence against
them so I think we need to present it to
rape complainants and genuine rape and
rape victims as a difficult horrible
process that has to be gone through in
order to ensure that everyone has a fair
hearing and it's only if we have that
that the conviction that results from
that process can be said to be sound
well what about this come just I'm
sticking with the theme of rape culture
so you mentioned that the you know there
are some police officers you're still
living in in the 70s you mentioned that
the the criminal justice system is
essentially by design I it's a painful
or unpleasant process to go through you
know that there's we even though you
mentioned that there's data to show that
what the the woman was wearing doesn't
affect the jury's decision you know we
do see these stories like the Irish
rugby players or whatever where that
seemed to have been a topic of
discussion isn't like when you put all
the stuff together
he certainly if I was complainant in one
of these cases I would think that the
system is stacked against me someone
who's simply a victim of a crime as
opposed to being stacked evenly or being
stacked against the person who did this
to me
yeah and therefore I would feel like
potentially you know we we do live in a
society which seems to you know not do
its best that at the very least to help
me as the victim in that situation I'm
there is some truth in that and there is
a risk of that that when you pick up the
phone to the
police that they're not going to do the
best job they possibly can that is a
risk that all victims of crime face but
one thing I think is vital and this was
you know pointed out in the Baroness
Stern report from 2010 is that we can't
be overly pessimistic with people making
these complaints because then they won't
come forward at all so we can point to
an unusually high conviction rate once
the case gets to court we can talk about
massive reforms in favor of increasing
the resources to the police greater
understanding within the police of of
how these complaints unfold and once the
complaint is made people can be
relatively confident that the allegation
will be treated fairly and investigated
the other but but one other point to
make is that the system is stacked
against complainants not stacked against
complainants but it is stacked against
the state so when someone makes an
allegation you are inviting the state to
prosecute someone and our justice system
is set up so that defendants who are
individuals have more have we have to
try and level the playing field between
an individual who's being prosecuted by
a state who can marshal enormous
resources against them so there is a
sense in which the process is stacked
against complainants but but it's that
stacking against that actually makes the
process fair because we have to bring
the defendant up to the position of a
level playing field with the state and
that's a difficult thing to do but I
think what so just going back to what we
should what we should tell complainants
about this process is look this is a
crime that you're making an allegation
of the allegation must be investigated
robustly and fairly that will involve
testing your account to make sure that
it's true and also that if later on when
the case comes before court that we've
tested it early to make sure that it can
stand up to the kind of scrutiny it's
going to get in the courtroom
complainants must be told that once it
gets into the courtroom that process is
going to be hard and they're going to be
challenged but none of this tells should
tell a complainant that they've got no
chance of getting their case disposed of
in a fair way
because all the evidence suggests that
assuming everything goes right and
that's a very difficult assumption to
make for all criminal offenses because
the police is understaffed the CPS are
understaffed etc but once it gets
actually into the system it has every
chance of being dealt with fairly and I
think that's the that's the that's one
message we've got to put forward now
that's one one aspect I find there's a
real risk that we're overly optimistic
and people like me who work in the
system come across as saying all the
courts work brilliantly
and no one ever has any difficulties
that's just not true and we that I see
probably the same amount of cases
investigated well as I see investigated
badly but it would be wrong for
complainants to believe that no matter
who they come forward to at the police
no matter what happens they won't be
taken seriously and that sometimes is
the narrative that is prevalent and I
think that's a dangerous one hi guys
we've got a returning sponsor this week
which is beer 52 that's b-52 dot-com now
before any we go any further you might
notice we are in a little bit of a
different environment and that's because
we're in my bedroom or as it otherwise
known ladies the pleasure done b-52 have
got a wonderful offer fee where you can
get eight delicious craft beers for a
fiver that's a delicious craft beers for
five pound what can you get for five
pounds maybe a pint in London maybe six
chicken nuggets I mixed chicken nuggets
the great thing about beer 52 is that
every month they'll send you a different
case of beers from a different part of
the world recent themes have included
journey the elks career
what is the Alps even a country now this
is net country so if you want to access
its incredible offer all you need to do
is go to WWE
you'll be able to get eight delicious
beers delivered to your door
that's www.behr.com forward slash
trigger and you'll get those eight
delicious beers direct to your door what
else are you gonna do so recently one of
Britain's most prolific rapists
was arrested and convicted I can't
remember the young man's name I think he
was based in Manchester yeah now I think
it was a hundred and thirty six I may
have been slightly incorrect on the
number of curve of incidences that you
know he's raped someone and and I read
this you know I don't know anything
about this and I think number one how is
he able to get away with this for so
long
without the police tracking him down
surely there must be some level of
incompetence there when it comes to
policing investigations how has he
managed to slip through the net and when
we talk about rape we obviously we seem
to because we talk about women but we
don't seem to talk a lot about male rape
is that because it's a very very small
issue and it doesn't tend to happen or
is it a taboo that we simply don't
discuss it is it's not a small issue for
the people involved yeah socially it's a
lot smaller issue than it is for women
so I think about it's about tenth I
think of the complainants are male that
the specifics of the case you're talking
about I mean they were unique this was a
young man who had drugged people he'd
found on the street a lot of them
weren't aware when they woke up in his
flat that they've been attacked and it
was interesting I got involved in a
discussion about whether it was right
for the police to once they found the
videos on the chaps phone you know he
was discovered by accident you know he'd
so he'd he'd made a complaint to the
police about someone who had been out
with and it was only once they took his
phone
they found reams and reams of videos of
this this violence occurring so they
found him by accident and he was not the
most prolific rapist in the UK's ever
seen so I don't think it's incompetence
that was just a very difficult offense
to identify because a lot of the people
had been attacked while they were under
the influence of drugs that had been
administered to them without their
permission but that's not to say that I
mean male rape is a distinct issue but
it's it's it's nonetheless a narrow
section of the totality of the offending
I think but that's to say look it's also
true that we don't talk about
because it doesn't easily fit with the
with the narrative that this is a
culturally influenced problem it fits a
lot better when you understand that rape
is a crime of violence that can that
occurs between both men and women once
you understand it's a crime of violence
rather than the crime of sex you know
gender becomes largely irrelevant so I
think you're right in the sense that we
we should interrogate that side of the
debate more and I think it probably if
the reason we don't talk about it as
much because it doesn't fit into the
kind of politicized discussion we have
at the moment well you talk about the
politicized discussion and the narrative
so if what you're essentially saying is
that this idea of us living in a rape
culture as a myth which i think is what
you're saying I'm not putting words in
your mouth yeah yeah so the idea that
the culture we live in fosters an
environment in which sexual violence
becomes more likely I think is a myth
and a dangerous one I've put the title
of my book hmm that's not to say they're
on but the point of the book was to the
reason why and the rape culture idea is
a myth is because it's too simplistic by
far the reality and that's not to say
that all the claims made by those who
argue that there is a rape culture are
wrong
they're not although they just don't
back up the argument that there's a rape
culture we get it yeah that they kind of
take a very narrow view and then expand
it to a particular social theory which I
don't think is right
so my question was going to be why is it
then if this if a lot of the claims that
are made are not true and the broader
allegation that we live in this culture
is not true why is there this narrative
why is it that you know I keep being
told that I need to you know not listen
to a song because I'm one song away from
becoming a rapist because all men are
potential rapists why when the evidence
is quite clear the people who commit
rape or rapist this is not men right why
is it that we keep being bombarded with
this kind of idea that all men are
potentially violent in that way well one
thing is that is interesting is I think
that that argument is actually one thing
I've noticed the difference between 2015
and now is that arguments made less
often now we
interesting you know it has fallen away
a little bit if you remember back to
2015 this was everywhere it was a real
part of that yeah of the culture war in
a way which now maybe perhaps slightly
less but um I think part of the reason
is that the origin of this idea comes
from a particularly radical section of a
feminist academia people as Brown Miller
in the in the 80s who were saying
precisely that every single man has the
potential to be a rapist and even most
forms of sex are in some form rape you
know that they went as far as to say
that and those ideas were prevalent
amongst in particular I'm at a very
narrow section of feminist academia for
it for it for a while
and I think some of that influence still
maintains among particular academic
circles so what we've seen I think over
the last 10 years is a shift from
focusing on the material factors which
prevent rape being dealt with
effectively so for example in the 1980s
academics could point to particular laws
which for example a 24-hour limit on
reporting which was across a lot of
states in the United States and
throughout the 1980s they could point to
a lot of concrete factors which actually
prevented rape being dealt with
adequately so I think in New York if you
didn't report right within 24 hours then
the cases would not proceed which is
remarkable they could also point to
factors in English law such as it was
not against the law to rape your wife
until you know the midnight you know mid
to late 90s and there are a number of
judicial decisions that they could point
to which really stack the system further
against the complainant so they were
real in in the past 80s and 90s I think
there are real concrete factors that
were still in the way of dealing with
this case with this offense properly as
those have fallen away what I think
we've seen is a shift of focusing on
individual attitudes so in recent years
you've seen the kind of explosion of
research into what they call rape myths
and these are it's psychological
research into members of the public and
their attitudes towards particular
offenses particularly rape and they use
the so you'll see headlines very often
that say
psychological research says that for
example jurors think that if you've been
sexually assaulted you should react in a
particular way where the research shows
the sexual victims of sexual violence
reacts in a complex myriad of ways and
not necessarily one way or the other so
we've seen a shift away from identifying
the concrete factors which prevent this
offense being dealt with to focus on
individual attitudes in the research and
that still allows them that still allows
a particular section of academia to
propagate the idea that it's a cultural
sociological problem at the level of
people you know people are influenced by
the culture that enables sexual violence
and they're so they're so imbued with
retrograde attitudes about women that
this offense isn't being dealt with
properly but I do think that the reason
why that remains a myth is because they
ignore the real advances that in part
they ignore the real advances that we've
had in dealing with these case you know
all those retrograde appalling laws have
peeled away over time and you know
juries are now directed on not relying
on myths like oh she was wearing a short
skirt she was up for it you know going
into someone's house doesn't necessarily
mean consent they're directed with all
of those things we've discussed that
statistics around jury decision-making
which shows absolutely no evidence of
bias so there has been real progress in
that regard and I think that's why now
we see this explosion of research into
rape myths and rape myth attitudes and
you know there was real problems with
that area of research you know my the
one of the reasons I was drawn into this
area to begin with was an old friend of
mine who sadly no longer with us Helen
Reese he was an amazing academic at the
London School of Economics and she got
she was very very far braver than I was
around this issue and published papers
around this area of research right as it
was starting to get momentum so she
wrote a piece a legal academic piece
about rape
myth research just raising some
questions about their methodology and
about the questions they were asking and
there was an explosion of reaction from
this particular section of academia and
it just struck me that for some for some
sections of
of academic feminism I think there's a
lot at stake because this issue has
politically galvanized them for a long
period of time and there's now a new
generation of academics coming up that
are practicing the particular area and
that's not to say that they're not
making an important contribution I think
their work has to be situated in a
broader context which says that you know
we shouldn't be frightening rape
complainants and rape victims away from
engaging with the system because it's
not inherently misogynistic really
anymore and they do have a good chance
at a fair hearing a statistic that is
always raised is the fact that the vast
majority of people are sexually abused
or raped by somebody that they know it's
a very very rare that you get your John
Wall boys you know that sort of prolific
sex offender who is incredibly predatory
and preys on strangers most people who
do these horrendous crimes they know
that they know the victims that
essentially groomed them and then this
happens is that true and therefore does
it make it less likely that somebody
will report it if it's somebody who is
you know a beloved family friend yeah
relative uncle whatever well this very I
mean you're right in the sense that most
rape defendants are known to their
victim in my experience a lot of the
time known too is quite a broad category
so it might be someone at their
university or someone at their and
someone who they've a friend of a friend
or something similar I don't think it's
as I hope I've communicated it's
difficult to make any generalizations
about who is more likely to than not
commit these kinds of offenses but I
think in general what what that what
this might reflect is that recent
changes in in the law have made it have
broadened the deaf you know broadened
the category of rape I think that's a
fair thing to say it's it's broadly
acknowledged that the new the changes to
the law that came in in 2003 broadened
our understanding of what rape was and
that was a very good development in some
ways because you know
you don't have to go back that far to a
time when people didn't believe that
anyone who'd been on a date and had
subsequently been raped couldn't have
been right because they were on a date
you know we just didn't accept that that
was true
now the category has widened to such an
extent that I think a lot of sexual
encounters which once might have been
understood as difficult or troubling now
get re recast as rape and sexual
violence I think there's a risk there
that's the risk of expanding the law is
that more and more of these interactions
become drawn into that net which I think
we've discussed previously but that
might be one reason why people are more
willing to come forward and make
allegations about people they know
because our understanding of what it is
has expanded and that comes with
benefits but it also comes with risks
and I think that's what we've got to
understand that there's a duality of it
it's not it's not that you know we need
to refine our understanding of road to
be very very straightforward and well
we're only going to prosecute this
running in a prosecute that but we uh
need to understand that the expansion
that's taken place over the last 20
years has benefits but also risks and is
there any truth I know you said there's
no correlation between and you know and
we shouldn't generalize but it is a
retrouver abused then gone to become
abusers or again is that another myth
that has been the honest answer is I
don't know and the but but I think that
it's very difficult always to firstly
it's difficult to establish a
correlation but then a correlation is
never a causation and I think the
troubling and every single statistic you
can pick out around this crime can be
interpreted in a thousand different ways
so that's what makes it very difficult
to talk about but the honest answer is I
don't know whether there is even a
correlation but finally you've asked a
bad question well just before we've got
a little bit of time left I want to ask
you I think it's a very difficult
question but I'm gonna ask you anyway
because you talked about this what the
person was wearing thing and there's
always the conversation like how do you
teach people how to prevent a crime from
occurring without placing the blame on
them
for a crime occurring and we seem to
have completely lost the ability to have
an honest conversation about that you
know what I mean like I remember I was
walking through a rough part of
Edinburgh taking a couple of speakers
stereo speakers to a friend's house and
I was acutely aware that I was walking
through a rough area with something that
people may want to take from me using
violence right and so I think I put them
in a bag and I hit them do you know what
I'm getting that I do so how do we have
that conversation honestly because I
mean I would argue that it is unarguable
that if dressing in a certain way would
encourage male attention and therefore
expose you to risks right as a woman so
how did how do you talk about preventing
crime without placing the blame on
people who should not be blamed for a
crime being committed against them yeah
I mean my response is no not to tell
women how to dress yeah and not - yeah
but I'm rushing mate so you know I don't
have those limitations so I I mean um
the response should never be for women -
I sort of am sympathetic to the idea
that the response to rape should not be
tell women to behave differently sure
because that in itself mischaracterizes
the nature of what rape is sure and it
conflates it with sex and an attraction
that stuff so I guess what I'm saying is
if I think I think I think I've got an
answer - oh sorry yeah which to go back
to the this stuff around and rape myths
so Helen I'm crediting her with this
because it was her point really she
identified a survey that was put out in
around 2004 and the report of the survey
was one in three women think that rape
victims are partly to blame for what's
happened to them partly to blame when
you looked at the research what these
women had been asked was do people
involved in these cases take have some
responsibility for what happened to them
and what Helen identified was that there
was a huge difference between
responsibility
and blame okay so I think women tend to
realize you know I think all women
realize that they have some
responsibility for their own behavior
you know and women realize that they are
responsible for their interactions with
other human beings you know goes without
saying that's not the same thing as to
say that women should be blamed for
what's happened to them because blame
should not figure at all so it's about
the way we have the discussion is to is
to really draw out the distinction
between responsibility and blame we can
say that women are smart enough to know
that if they go out on a date with a guy
and they invite him up after the end of
the date when there would be no when you
know when they have a reason to go their
separate ways
that's not consenting to sex but there
is a sexual connotation to that decision
yeah and to pretend that most women
don't know that already is ridiculous
yeah so a lot of the discussion around
rape culture pretends that there is no
content to that decision whatsoever most
women know that there is you know the
example that Helen used in the in the
paper was is coming up for coffee
suggestive of sex
now of course inviting someone up for
coffee is not consent to sex but also
most people most men and women
understand that that is a form of social
communication and also most people
understand that consent and the kind of
the process that leads up to a sexual
encounter is a deeply intimate difficult
human process that is often worked out
between the parties as it unfolds you
know when you sleep with someone for the
first time you are attempting to read
signals all the time right that's an
organic difficult process that involves
you know assumptions from both parties
it involves differences of
interpretation and I think what was so
valuable about Helens work was that it
was saying these aren't necessarily
myths they are the categories of
understanding that we all bring to those
moments you know
when you're out on a day or when you're
out you know when you when you when
you're first engaging in these kinds of
liaisons with a new person it involves
uncertainty and it involves risk right
it's risky because you're putting
yourself out there in a way which is
difficult and it involves a negotiation
between two people right it's a it's a
mutual dance and the cop that the the
American feminist writer Camille Palio
put it in quite strong terms she said
that female freedom is the freedom to
risk being raped now that's a very
strong way of putting it but what she
was talking about there was that if you
believe in women's sexual liberation
which I think most people in the Western
world tend to do you know they believe
that men and women should have equal
rights to sexual liberation then that
always comes with a degree of risk
because sex and intimacy occurs in an
unregulated space between human beings
for now for now but it doesn't it
hopefully remains a kind of uncontrolled
sphere where people have to work it out
for themselves
so the the book talks that my book talks
about the risk that the expansion of the
law necessarily involves a contraction
of that space where we're left to figure
it out for ourselves and so I think the
way we have this discussion is to get
rid of the gendered men and women men
are bad women are women a feckless
discussion completely we just need to
recognize that when people go out and
starting to live and interact with
people they are going to take risks that
it's a little bit dangerous always but
that's what's great about it that we're
both to some degree responsible for what
happens in the course of those
interactions that that doesn't translate
into being blamed if something goes
terribly wrong but at the end of the day
this is an organic process between two
individuals that will be unpredictable
dangerous but also you know quite
exciting you know for that reason it's
exciting because it's unpredictable and
that's easy for me to say as a man
obviously because I'm inherently less
likely to be at risk but the
we can't completely drain that
interaction of any risk because if we do
that it's not the interaction that we
started out with and look this is
another question which is quite
difficult to ask in that so I used to
work in a pub for many many years and
you see couples come in or they're on a
date and you know especially in Britain
we've got such a you know a large
drinking culture that by the end you see
these couples tottering out absolutely
you know leathered and you think reality
is anybody able to give consent at this
point and how difficult does that make a
conviction if you know the woman wakes
up and she realizes something untoward
has happened goes into a police station
and they go right go through the list of
events of what's happened and she's
drunk and she doesn't really remember it
accurately or clearly well that as a
point of fact you can you can get a
conviction in a rape case even where the
complainant has absolutely no
recollection of what happened to them
so if they are completely incapacitated
and can't remember what happened a
prosecution is still possible they just
have to piece together evidence from
other areas so CCTV and piecing together
the account as best they can
there is a piece of law a case called
case called Bri which says that if
someone is incapable of forming consent
if they're so drunk that they're
incapable of giving consent then that's
capable of being rape you know you
shouldn't sleep with someone if they're
demonstrably and incapable of giving you
consent to sleep with them but what Bri
also says is that drunken consent is
also consent you know if you are capable
of forming that mindset of agreeing to
sexual intercourse and you do so then
that can constitute consent so and that
question as to whether someone was
capable of giving consent it's usually
left to the jury to decide so if you're
sat on a jury and you're considering a
case in which one person says I didn't
consent I was very very drunk and he
took advantage and the other party's
saying they did consent here's the
reasons why I thought they were
consenting then the issue for the jury
will usually be were they so drunk that
they couldn't form consent in their own
brain
and often actually like the drunk
consent cases are quite easy to pick
apart because you look at someone you
say well they're clearly not capable of
forming consent or you look at them and
you say well they appear to be compos
mentis they're able to stand etcetera
etc so that's a question for the jury so
it's a matter of fact that the jury has
to determine usually even some of the I
mean how many couples in this country
will go home from a pub one of Friday on
Saturday night completely as you say
leathered both very drunk and have sex
and not there is no issue there do you
not I mean it's just it's so cool this
is one so one just one very quick point
about the crime survey for England and
Wales being boring about research you
know what they that that's the crime
survey for England and Wales is where
people get the figure of eighty three
thousand rapes every year so that's an
often touted figure that there's 82,000
rapes every year the question that that
survey asked people was have you ever
been penetrated where you haven't given
consent or when you've been too drunk to
consent and lots of people said yeah
like over the last 12 months with my
partner with my husband or my long-term
boyfriend I've had sex in circumstances
where neither of us had a clue what was
going on right so that means yes that
gets recorded that's right an instance
of rape and what the crime survey did
was they stopped asking women about how
they themselves interpreted what had
happened to them right because when they
used to run the survey a bunch of women
turn around I said well I didn't and
just didn't consider that rape because
it's my boyfriend or my husband and we
were both Trollied and what I think that
illustrates is that sex is an intimate
thing and often the boundaries for what
accept what is acceptable and what is
not between a couple are negotiated
between them and it's not always easy to
put a simplistic understanding of what's
occurred on to it you can't really label
you know there's all sorts of things
that go on in the bedroom that you can't
label you know one thing or the other
because their individual and their
distinctive so that's one interesting
aspect of that so that couples will do
all sorts of things that the law is too
blunt to deal with and and shouldn't
have no involvement with but the risk is
that the more we expand the sphere of
the law into the air
the more likely is that these organic
you know intimate relationships are
drawn into a legal system that's
ill-equipped to deal with them
alright well our time is up I'm sure all
our viewers have enjoyed this cheery and
upbeat with lots of banter back and
forth but it's I mean it's a very
serious issue that requires that kind of
approach and that's why we've not tried
to you know sure Fanta where do you
worry about it
Luke remind everybody your book and
where to get it so two books first yes
right why rape culture is a dangerous
myth yeah published five years ago
but my latest book is human rights
illusionary freedom why we should repeal
the Human Rights Act and where can
people follow you on social media so
I've got ridiculous twitter handle which
is Lucas gives us 1986 well we'll stick
it in the video as always thank you for
watching and we'll see you in a week
with another brilliant episode see you
next week guys take care thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pot and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word